he only appeared in one episode of
faulty towers but bernard cribbins
perfectly timed performance as a
pretentious guest made for an enduring
classic i'm trying to say that this
hotel is extremely inefficient and badly
running you are a very rude and
discourteous man mr fault
in a career spanning seven decades he
was synonymous with the golden age of
british tv
from carry
on who are you
i'm wilfred mott to doctor who's
companion he gathered fans from every
generation
bernard uh uh
encompassed the word
icon
and and legend uh those two very
overworked and used words
because he appealed to every generation
he had that twinkle in his eye that made
children laugh and adore they'll
remember his
voice forever it was so soft and warm
and fun
and then adults would always know that
he was just having a little bit of a
giggle
this
is the home of the wombles he'll also be
remembered by many as a comforting
bedtime story voice from their childhood
tomsk is busy already and it's through
him many of us first learned about
recycling
oakworth this is awkward the new sequel
to the railway children gives a nod to
his character from the original we shot
in the same station that the original
was shot in and there's something about
that standing on that same platform as
bernard cribbins would have stood and
looking out across a landscape it hasn't
really changed much because such a
timeless quality to it that you can't
help but feeling in contact with the
past
timeless indeed is his legacy which
lives on for generations of fans who
will enjoy his work no doubt for decades
to come
claire gregory sky news